You know, it's been almost a year
since our staff started working remotely.
I really miss seeing
everyone around the office.
So I'm gonna check in with some staffers
who are working from home
and see what's new since
the last time I saw them.
[Together] Hi, Conan.
Hey Diane, what's new with you?
Well, I got a PhD in astrophysics
and I'm currently manning the Mars rover.
Perseverance, collect the geology samples.
Oh, that's cool.
What about you, Chris?
We bought a zoo and our
elephant just gave birth.
(elephant trumpeting)
Oh okay.
What about you Kathy?
I got a tattoo.
That's nice.
That's all you're gonna say?
I guess, so many things have
happened in the last year
that nothing really surprises me anymore.
I bet I can surprise you, Conan.
Jake from State Farm?
I'm here to tell you
about surprisingly great
rates from State Farm.
How can we compete with that?
Jake, how great are these
surprisingly great rates?
Check your inbox.
(phone notification beeping)
Are you kidding me?
I'm so surprised by these great rates.
These rates are unbelievable.
I'm losing my mind over these great rates!
Jake from State Farm, you did it again!
Yeah, Jake really did do it again.
(Conan laughing)